real quick go check out jayatal the uk's
most exciting electronic music duo their
newest release connected is available
wherever you get music it's energetic
melodic blast of electronica ingeniously
infused with acoustic instruments and
they support the david pakman show check
them out using the link below
we're starting today with the president
yes the president joe biden who is
showing more signs of life than we've
seen for months from the standpoint of
his presidency joe biden
riding high on a number of major
accomplishments went to wilkes-barre
pennsylvania yesterday
and he
absolutely crushed republicans
republicans who are now openly
threatening violence we covered two days
ago republican senator lindsey graham
saying if trump is indicted there will
be riots in the street yeah it'll be
trumpists rioting in the streets we know
lindsay
and joe biden with i i have to say i
you know i'm not adding a value judgment
to this
but joe biden more fired up and
energetic i would argue that i have seen
him his entire presidency
as we are now just weeks from the 2022
midterms on which so much ride
take a look at this so let me say this
to my mag of republican friends in
congress yeah
don't tell me you support law
enforcement
if you won't condemn what happened on
the sixth right don't tell me
right
can't do it
[Applause]
for god's sake whose side are you on
not long whose side are you on
[Applause]
look
simple
you're on the side of a mob
for the side of the police you can't be
pro law enforcement and pro-insurrection
you can't be a party of law and order
and call the people who attacked the
police on january 6 patriots right you
can't do it
what are we teaching our children
it's just that simple
and now it's sickening
to see the new attacks in the fbi
threaten the life of law enforcement
agents and their families for simply
carrying out the law and doing their job
look
listen
um
we saw this type of thing from
california governor gavin newsom about a
month ago and i told you that without
endorsing his entire political worldview
that it was the exact right approach to
dealing with these modern mega
republicans
democrats have to be aggressive
democrats in some cases have to be
ruthless it doesn't mean we do the
things they do we don't tell lies we
don't deal
but we have to adopt
this approach
and democrats should be looking at the
approach that gavin newsom is taking
democrats should be looking at this
particular version of joe biden and can
just think about the opposite for a
second imagine if you had
democrats
openly threatening law enforcement in
the way that republicans have done after
january january 6th excuse me after the
search warrant being carried out at
mar-a-lago just the republicans would be
saying forget about due process throw
him in prison for life and i was glad to
also see joe biden call out lindsey
graham lindsey graham who
predicted by which i mean threatened or
promised
riots if donald trump were to be
indicted it's a great thing that joe
biden is going right after him as well
no one expects politics to be a patty
cake
they sometimes get mean as hell
but the idea you turn on the television
and see senior senators and congressmen
saying if such and such happens
there'll be blood in the street
where the hell are we right and of
course a direct reference there to
lindsey graham
this is
a much more interesting joe biden look
at the joe biden of the last three
months number one rhetorically fiery
again energetic
accomplished more during his covet
isolation than trump did his entire
presidency if you can imagine that and
now we see a great jobs report inflation
is down gas prices are down the
inflation reduction act has been passed
the pact act the infrastructure i mean i
could go on and on i'm not going to give
you the full list every single time but
accomplishment after accomplishment
after accomplishment this is a very
different joe biden than we saw earlier
in the presidency or sort of in the
middle of the presidency and it's also a
democratic party whose chances in
november of 2022 are looking
dramatically better so we're going to
follow it very closely and by the way in
the middle of all of this
we are seeing
some republicans
some republicans
so disgusted
by the low quality candidates that their
primary voters have selected to
represent them in november
that in some races republicans are
increasingly endorsing democrats and
that's what we're going to talk about
next
in pennsylvania a disgusting man
has been nominated by republicans
to potentially be the next governor of
pennsylvania and sadly it is a man named
doug mastriano
who if given the opportunity in 2024 to
steal pennsylvania for the eventual
republican presidential nominee he would
do it
there are two choices in pennsylvania
for governor there's doug mastriano who
is a big lie promulgator
and a guy who would do all the things
trump wanted governors to do for him in
2020 and then you've got democratic
nominee josh shapiro there's not that
much to say about josh shapiro he's a
completely
standard
milk toast and i don't say that in a
pejorative just he's just a normal
democrat who wouldn't do anything crazy
he wouldn't try to steal an election and
that's pretty damn good right now
because of what the republican party has
become
and now to add on to the absurdity of
doug mastriano
it turns out that doug mastriano once
donned a confederate uniform
confederate uniform while he was in the
military
and as a result more and more
republicans
are endorsing his democratic opponent
josh shapiro business insider reports
seven more republican leaders endorsed
democrat josh shapiro for pennsylvania
governor following news of mastriano
wearing a confederate military uniform
seven more republicans have announced
their endorsement for democrat josh
shapiro one month after nine republicans
called his republican opponent dog
master doug mastriano an extremist a
photo obtained by reuters showed
mastriano posing in a confederate
military uniform
um
this is the picture which we're putting
up on the screen for you here
and it is completely vile this is a
picture from 2014
it was taken while then state senator
doug mastriano was part of the faculty
at the u.s army war college
faculty members were permitted to pose
for the photo while dressed as
historical figures
and masteriano chose
a confederate
a confederate
uniform
and now is losing the support of at
least a number of republicans
so you know we can talk all day
about the confederate uniform we can say
well you know it's
it is a historical reality
that there were confederate soldiers
and so it's not
necessarily reflective of his problem
right i'm an idiot i sound like an idiot
when i try to try to say this uh okay
the fact that he is wearing the uniform
alone doesn't mean doug mastriano wishes
we could bring br back uh the enslaving
of black people i'm not saying that but
this is all part of a picture right this
is all part of the bigger picture about
doug mastriano and who he is
uh big lie conspiracy theorist unhinged
number one
secondly
has this campaign advisor who is overtly
as anti-semitic as anyone i've ever
heard of short of you know right i mean
world war ii era german leaders
um
said that
jews don't even have a place in the
republican party even if they're
conservative disgusting right and then
masteriano wears a confederate uniform
so we're building up a picture that is
based on a number of different pillars
and they're all disgusting rotting
pillars covered in pond scum so it would
be great
on the one hand
if the more moderate establishment
republicans
jump ship
from these disgusting maga people that's
a good thing because we want the maga
people to lose
on the other hand if it goes too far
those very
moderate republicans might end up
running as democrats and it could end up
moving the democratic party to the right
which we also don't want we want the
democratic party moving to the left um
and so that's a consideration and that's
a concern as well but it's really
important
really important i mean pennsylvania is
one of the most important states
uh and and you know i'm not saying some
states don't matter
but
you know
wyoming even though liz cheney lost her
primary that's going to be a republican
member of congress either way wyoming is
not going to be the difference maker
over the next two years in the united
states on the other hand look at
pennsylvania pennsylvania is a state on
which control of the senate could hinge
meaning that the oz versus fetterman
race is extraordinarily important and
pennsylvania is a state on which the
2024 presidential election could hinge
and thus having a governor in
pennsylvania who won't try to steal the
state's electors for the candidate that
didn't win that's an important thing and
so that's why we need josh shapiro to be
the next governor of pennsylvania
not doug mastriano who is just
absolutely and completely vile so
if you're
if you live in pennsylvania of course
you should vote in both of those
elections but no matter where you live
you can phone bank and you can donate in
those two races and they are very very
important races
uh just masteriano is disgusting he's
really the worst of the worst of magat
politics
and hopefully we can defeat him in
november
and then he just goes away today is the
david pakman show member town hall the
day has finally come wednesday august
31st unless you're listening to this on
a different day wednesday august 31st is
today at 6 pm eastern time 3 p.m pacific
we will be doing a member town hall it
will be broadcast for all to see on
youtube twitch and facebook but for this
particular one the participants will be
our members at joinpackman.com and you
can sign up right up until the start of
the town hall at joinpacman.com so that
you can participate today
one of our sponsors today is jayatal
jayatal is a stellar melodic dance music
duo in one of the uk's most exciting
electronic acts jayatal have made their
name through legendary live shows that
incorporate drums guitar electronics
taking them on tours across europe
they've appeared on bbc their newest
release called connected will knock you
off your feet written and recorded
entirely remotely during covid my
favorite track from the album is the one
you're hearing right now called it's
coming round again
[Music]
probably because i'm a drummer but i
love acoustic drums accompanied by a bed
of electronic layers and the track
really gets the drums going in all of
their music even something as simple as
the synth bass sounds like it was
carefully adjusted for hours to hit your
ear just the right way these guys will
take you on a journey and jayatal are
big fans of the david pakman show if you
like unusual but deeply gratifying
electronica check out jayatal on their
new release connected wherever you
stream or buy music they're on youtube
and social media you can book them for a
show and you can find them using the
link below
well my disappointment with podcaster
joe rogan continues to grow the latest
is that rogan called donald trump's
press secretary kaylee mcinanni
the michael jordan of press secretaries
the truth of course could not be more
different kaylee mcinanni one of the
most dishonest press secretaries that i
have ever covered and this dates back to
the george w bush administration quite
frankly um hard to find a more dishonest
press secretary now unfortunately i
think what rogan is falling prey to is
sometimes people sound really confident
but the things they say are absurd this
is sometimes called ben shapiro syndrome
where people will very confidently say
things that are wrong
dishonest absurd
pathetic not based in fact and kaylee
mcinanny did that she sounded very
confident but she didn't really answer
questions and she lied absolutely all
the time so this is part of the
continued disappointment with what has
been going on with rogan and again
speculation is he moved to texas reports
are he sometimes hangs around with
extremists like uh republican governor
greg abbott and others and there may be
some sort of i don't know about audience
capture but maybe like
um uh social circle capture of sorts
here's rogan talking about kaylee
mcinanny she was a propagandist i mean
when she's working for the white house
she's this person that
you know answers questions and most of
it the the hard questions are all by
peter ducey on fox so by the way the
here he's criticizing jensaki who is
biden's former press secretary
who i have to tell you by and large was
a more honest press secretary of course
of course they all spin but in terms of
out and out lies
saki was dramatically more honest than
any of trump's press secretaries news he
was like the only guy that was like like
pushing back against her and she just
flat out lied on not just one occasion
multiple occasions i mean maybe they had
a narrative that they told her maybe
these are talking parts maybe that's her
job but it's a weird job in the
beginning right
to begin with because it's a job where
you're not even asking the president
you're asking this white house press
secretary yeah so there's a person
you know the only one that was good at
the girl um
mckenna knee what's her name
kaylee mckinnony the one who worked for
trump that lady was a [ __ ] assassin that
lady had like binders with like
footnotes and they would say some shield
that's interesting because actually cnn
said this and right those were all
distortions and this is the problem with
optics and it's really sad you you
wouldn't necessarily think and in
rogan's defense not that i need to
defend him maybe he didn't really watch
an entire press briefing to understand
that the binders and the the confident
responses it was built on nothing it was
just smoke and mirrors and she would
like quote it back to them and stuff it
in their face that lady's the best ever
at that job she's the michael jordan of
white house press secretaries she's yeah
i mean obviously that it's really
disappointing to hear that because
a critical thinker
would say let's separate
uh let's separate substance
from uh tone and delivery let's separate
the facts or lack thereof
from the optics
and i mean listen
kaylee mcinanny promulgated the big lie
is there a bigger lie
than trump actually won the 2020
election and she lied endlessly beyond
that and defended the indefensible
everything that trump was doing
everything trump did she defended from
the you know coveted laced uh joy ride
with secret service around the hospital
like
i couldn't i could spend an hour giving
you the list
there was nothing she would not defend
so when we say she was great at her job
she sounded confident which is something
unfortunately lots of right wingers do
when they say things that are completely
untrue and bogus and of course you can
just go back and find all of the
different things that uh she lied about
mackinani made
weeks of press com press statements
about trump never downplayed coronavirus
trump literally said we have 15 cases
which will soon be zero there is no
bigger down playing than when you end up
with 100 million cases there's no bigger
downplaying than that and she did that
for weeks and weeks and weeks
she
made the same false claims about the
mueller report that trump would make it
exonerated him it literally did not
exonerate him it said we cannot clear
him of obstruction
the 2020 election lies um
constantly exaggerating number i'm not
going to bore you with it but the point
is hard to find a more dishonest press
secretary and sadly rogan seems to have
fallen for it
this is just unbelievable
there's now a picture
of the top secret documents
that trump had at mar-a-lago
and every detail is insane including the
crass cheesy casino-style carpets that
trump seems to love everywhere in his
residence but we're going to get to that
remember the shifting narratives we
didn't have any documents
if there were documents there the fbi
planted them well but they weren't
classified but they weren't secret well
they were but i declassified them
they're back to they were planted we'll
get to that tomorrow on and on and on
but all along
sowing doubt
we now have the pictures and it's wild
and there is reason to believe per the
feds now
that
the uh trump circle
was specifically trying to obstruct the
investigation by moving documents around
you you just have to see this to believe
it so first report associated press
fed site efforts to obstruct probe of
documents at trump estate
the justice department says classified
documents were likely concealed and
removed from a storage room at former
president donald trump's florida estate
as part of an effort to obstruct the
federal investigation into the discovery
of the government records so understand
the meaning of that okay
the trump people were insisting when
they asked us for the documents in june
we gave them to them when they told us
to put a lock on the door we put a lock
on the door we then get the affidavit
and there's nothing about a lock the
entire lock thing was just fabricated as
based on what we know right now nobody
ever said everything's cool as long as
you put a lock on the door a padlock if
you can imagine so that ends up being a
lie
and then also of course the idea that
they gave all the documents back is what
is obviously debunked by this picture
which we are putting up on the screen
for you and if you look at this picture
you see all sorts of documents some in
very very large letters marked secret or
top secret and they are on the floor of
trump's office you can see some framed
time magazine
covers on the right side of the image
and then you see uh these just
the casino rugs you know
it's a reminder that money can't buy you
class the fact that donald trump puts
literal casino rugs
in his uh office or bedroom or around
his toilet where wherever it is that
that this is uh this is absolutely
extraordinary absolutely extraordinary
and the report is that federal
prosecutors believe
that certain pages of the records were
actually torn up now if that is true for
a normal person you would be barred from
ever holding public office ever again in
the united states unfortunately that's
not really enough
prison is what is deserved remember
reality winner who ended up with uh
i don't want a mistake but was it was it
four or five years
for one page that we're talking about
one page
this is just pages upon pages upon pages
any one of which could could
dump people in prison
uh just for a single one and it's just
page after page with prosecutors
believing that some of these were torn
up so
there should be prison time that i'm not
making a prediction that there will be
but there should be prison time here and
then we of course have to go back to
what was the point of having these
documents and speculation
is quite uh abroad about what they were
there for is it that it was a way for
trump to stroke his own ego to show
visitors hey look at what i've got here
i've got the latest was
documents on emmanuel macron's sex life
or whatever not that those would
necessarily be the most uh most
classified but putting that aside was it
to stroke his ego by showing them to
people
i mean did he plan to sell them at some
point which is a whole other crazy thing
and it's speculative of course
one thing i'm increasingly thinking is
that law enforcement has not yet even
recovered all of the documents that
they're aware trump had at one point it
seems to me particularly with this
paragraph about there's a belief some
documents some pages were torn up and
why the hell would some of them be torn
up again
we can only speculate about why that
would be
my guess is part of the reason that this
is all happening is the fbi
still to this day as we are about to
start september of 2022 doesn't actually
have uh knowledge of the whereabouts of
every single one of these documents so
as far as prison someone must be heading
to prison i i don't expect it to be
trump
but could this end up being it's all an
oopsy and no one is going to prison at
all for the increasingly egregious
violations that we are learning about
taking place here uh it it it would be
stunning if that were the case and the
picture is just too much now initially
it was believed or reported
that the documents splayed all over the
floor was how they were found by the fbi
it that appears not to be the case it
seems as though they were placed on the
floor
with an exhibit number in order to be
photographed by the fbi but that they
were not actually found in that state if
they were that's even crazier like
trump's just storing them all over the
floor stranger things have happened but
it doesn't actually appear that that's
the case and one growing source of
trouble and strife for donald trump is
that this entire search warrant
situation
uh trump is not having his legal fees
paid by the republican national
committee anymore and that's a big
problem for trump and we're going to
talk about that next you might remember
we talked um
one maybe two months ago
about the republican national committee
telling trump
if you declare
that you're running for the presidency
before the midterms we're not going to
pay your legal fees anymore
and this raised two interesting topics
one was
wow
the rnc believes maybe correctly that
trump declaring his
candidacy now would be bad for
republicans in november and that
probably is true
and then the second revelation was the
rnc is paying trump's legal fees what's
the deal with that and the most likely
conclusion that most of you came to
based on the people that emailed me is
the rnc is incentivized to pay trump's
legal fees so that he maybe keeps
himself out of some trouble that could
be even more damaging to our candidates
our being the republican party in
november but it's all very speculative
and very very uh sort of nebulous
we now have learned that the rnc is not
paying trump's legal fees for what's
going on at mar-a-lago
uh and we have a number of different
articles about this and one of them
politico is really the main
news outlet reporting this in an article
called trump adds former florida
solicitor general to legal team working
mar-a-lago probe a few paragraphs in you
see trump will have to pay on his own a
person familiar with the matter
confirmed that the rnc is not paying for
trump's legal fees related to the fbi's
investigation and retrieval of documents
at mar-a-lago that's a departure of
sorts from the past the rnc has for
example paid trump's legal bills
involving new york attorney general tish
james's investigation the committee
would stop paying trump's legal fees
should he formally declare his candidacy
a step he has hinted at but has yet to
take so this actually has a number of
different potential implications number
one
trump has been extra flipping out in
public and a little bit later in the
show we're going to look at trump did a
60 post
sort of apoplectic tirade on troth
central yesterday 60 posts including q
on conspiracy theories part of trump
being extra unhinged may be
uh that they're no longer paying his
legal fees
and um the second element of this is
this might explain why donald trump is
having so much trouble finding good
lawyers
um they probably know the lawyers that
without the backing of the rnc for the
legal bills they're probably never going
to get paid and i you know every time
i've
dealt with a lawyer they go send me a
five grand retainer up front and i'll
start billing out of that five grand i'm
guessing with trump they're having
trouble uh getting the getting the
upfront retainer money but this could
explain why trump is having trouble
finding lawyers as well
um and it could be a very very crazy
eight weeks between now and the midterms
and there is an indictment watch i mean
it's kind of a weird term because
we're likely to learn about it after the
fact but there is now a open discussion
about
more like when will the indictment
happen rather than if
although i suggest we still wait before
we assume that that will take place so
trump now
paying or not really i guess we could
say
responsible for his own legal fees but
whether he will pay them is a different
issue we will have all of these images
and pictures and videos
including the one of the secret
documents in trump's house on our
instagram which you can find at david
pakman show also by the way if you want
to see some wacky wacky hate mail i got
follow me on instagram david.pacman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
it's great to welcome back to the
program today congressman ro khanna who
represents california's 17th district uh
congressman you know i have to say over
the last three months there has sort of
been new life breathed into the biden
administration and joe biden a number of
legislative accomplishments he seems
significantly more energetic
arguably one of the most productive
coveted isolation periods of anyone i
can think of uh joe biden had a couple
of months ago do you get the sense that
this will impact november's midterms for
democrats in the house like you or that
these are really
uh siloed accomplishments that that the
biden administration is experiencing
there is sense of momentum and that's
because democrats are delivering the
president delivered student debt relief
we're bringing manufacturing back to
america with the semiconductor bill that
i led with ships in science we are have
the largest investment in climate in
american history so there's a sense that
what the president said he would do what
we said we would do in 2020 we are doing
uh and that is finally breaking through
and there's also a sense that the
democratic party is more unified than
we've been probably since the beginning
of the president's term yeah that that
seems absolutely to be taking place and
when you particularly contrast to what's
happening in the republican party where
the rnc is stopping paying trump's legal
bills and you're seeing
um significant disagreements
on what the 2024 republican nomination
should look like and whether the
presence of people like liz cheney is
even
remotely welcome it does seem like there
is significantly more unification among
the democratic party
and also on some issues there seems to
be disagreement i mean the student loan
debt relief is an example where you have
some who believe
even on the democratic side there should
be no such debt relief at all people
decided to take out these loans and they
should pay the loans on the other hand
individuals who say all student loan
debt should be forgiven and then folks
kind of in the middle who say well some
some debt relief is a good idea where
are you on further debt relief
i'm forgetting debt relief up to fifty
thousand i mean the reality is uh ten
thousand dollars is often what it costs
someone to do one semester at a college
uh or one year at a community college
it's not enough but i applaud the
president for taking a major step uh
this is going to help a lot of working
and middle class folks uh it is again a
precedent for doing more
so i want to applaud him but say that
the job is not done
on the manufacturing jobs
explain to us exactly how one brings a
job back to the united states
from overseas where that will increase
the total cost to produce whatever is
being produced without making inflation
worse like what's the economic sequence
wherein we can do that
actually producing more things in the
united states could help long-term with
inflation i mean one of the reasons we
had inflation is we didn't make masks
here we didn't make semiconductors here
so you have to ship them from overseas
at 15 000 shipping per container as
opposed to two thousand dollars and the
fact that we didn't have enough
production uh meant that we had too much
money chasing too few goods if you
increase production long term uh that is
deflationary but you're saying in a
micro case well how are you going to
produce it here when wages may be higher
when environmental standards may be
higher i think that's why you need both
government collaboration in terms of
financing i mean other countries have
helped finance new factories new
industries government support on
the workforce development at community
colleges uh and a uh a collective
regional economic development effort
that's
what we did with fdr to build our
economy and there's no reason we can't
do it now yeah i mean i guess the
shipping is certainly a factor but 15
000 versus two for a shipping container
paying dramatically lower wages on every
unit on an ongoing basis seems like it
would be it would override the shipping
cost i mean i guess it depends on the
product and we'd have to sort of look at
the details but it seems also there
probably has to be some shift in the
thinking from the american
public
about the advantages to domestic
manufacturing as well and and i don't
know that the messaging is really there
on that
well i'm not sure it requires a a change
in consumer behavior obviously it'd be
great to to buy american but you could
have government purchasing american with
all the purchasing power we have that
will make a difference
second a lot of the advanced
manufacturing
has uh much less labor costs because of
automation uh it has increased
productivity now people say well this
means less jobs which is true but those
are going to be higher paying jobs and
it's going to mean more competitiveness
for the product so i think when it comes
to advanced manufacturing interval
interwoven textiles for example as
opposed to traditional manufacturing
that can be done here and will be done
here and the quality is often higher
here
that's not just an opinion the
productivity of american workers is more
than germany uh or japan and so i think
we have to be very deliberate about the
type of production that can be done uh
the government uh partnership that is
required uh and we can do it in a way
that is cost competitive yeah you know
one one uh high-tech product that is
being manufactured at least partially in
the united states is tesla electric
vehicles and it's been very interesting
to see that many on the right
you would think as i outlined yesterday
they should love electric vehicles you
can
charge them at home with solar panels
you own and not be depend right there's
the self-sufficiency aspect to it for
people who like fast cars which are
associated with alpha males in some
right wing circles electric vehicles are
very fast there's all these reasons why
the right should really be embracing
electric vehicles and yet
they seem almost angry about them to
some degree your colleague marjorie
taylor green and many others are furious
about electric vehicles are you
surprised by the antipathy towards them
from some on the right
i'm not because unfortunately climate
has become so politicized that anything
that is almost good for the climate uh
generates uh skepticism uh on the right
and that's why i think we could just
talk about
the new industrialization of america
let's build the new industries new
factories here it turns out a lot of
that uh will be clean a lot of that is
going to be clean steel new batteries
new electric vehicles new charging
station hydrogen jets hydrogen planes
we can talk about building new factories
new industry new manufacturing and that
may
cut across the uh the the political
divide on uh on cannabis
decriminalization you and i have spoken
about this before
my sense has been it's never been a
particularly interesting topic for
president joe biden but at the same time
i didn't think he was going to do any
student loan debt relief and i was very
very much wrong there do you get any
sense that there may be something before
november on cannabis from
the oval office
i don't you know i obviously am not just
for decriminalizing it i'm taking i'm
for taking it off schedule c for
legalizing uh marijuana uh but uh i i
think this is something that's personal
for the president my understanding is
that he has had people
with substance abuse in his own family
that that is informing his view it's
obviously a view that i uh
disagree with but because it's something
that
seems to be a
sincerely held conviction on his part
one that i disagree with i'm not sure
that uh we're going to see movement on
that do you expect that on the in the
long term
the cannabis issue is going to be dealt
with more at the state level as it has
been so far or that at some point there
will be a federal change
i think it's going to start at the state
level but uh my sense is within the next
uh
couple cycles presidential cycles
there'll be a federal change because you
have people on the republican side
the younger generation that understands
the importance of uh
legalizing cannabis and the medical uses
and the fact that uh cannabis often is
less
uh dangerous certainly less dangerous
than the opioids uh and yet more
restricted than some of the opioids
um let's talk a little bit about the
upcoming midterms so if we want to take
just one forecast the 538 forecast says
it's roughly a two to one chance that
democrats hold the senate and by a
roughly four to one margin democrats are
likely to lose the house now on the
house some of the recent momentum you
mentioned is not really in those numbers
quite yet but it's a pretty significant
hill to climb at this point and sort of
the most mathematically likely outcome
is a divided congress it seems to me
that this will be two years of total
republican obstruction to prevent any
major legislation
and then using the lack of
accomplishments that they cause as
justification
to vote for a republican president in
2024 that seems to be that what the game
plan is going to be are you and your
colleagues talking about that as the
most likely outcome and what what can be
done if anything
well we're still hopeful that we can
hold a house especially after new york
19 and uh there's a surprising result
there where pat ryan wasn't expected to
win uh abort he really ran on abortion
rights we're seeing as you know
increased registration among young women
in particular uh in ohio in pennsylvania
so uh are we underdogs to hold the house
yes of course the president's party
always loses seats we're in a tough
economic climate but we're still focused
on how we do that and the argument that
we're making to to be able to do that is
where is the republican agenda i mean uh
we have an agenda i can tell you what we
will do on inflation we're going to try
to get child care done we're going to
make sure that we uh are providing
greater uh benefits for for medicare
we're going to increase the social
security we're going to produce more
things in
america the republicans have no
agenda they're basically just running uh
anti uh uh by them yeah it's basically
just obstruct there's no doubt about
that but that nonetheless
if they successfully do that for two
years
it's not a super strong argument for
democrats to say well yes we got nothing
done but it wasn't our fault i mean it
just it doesn't sound like the type of
thing that voters will buy so what do
you do if that does end up being the
situation
well it depends i mean obviously
president obama and president clinton
had obstructionist republican congresses
that both won reelection and they did it
by showing just how extreme
the republican congress's work right so
it depends on uh whether the republicans
overplay their hand which they're very
capable of doing i mean if all they're
doing when they take uh power is trying
to impeach joe biden and do hearings on
hunter biden and all the other
conspiracy theories uh then i think the
american public will tire off that and
say we need more reasonable people uh i
i
in the past when they've had the
majority they have overreached so
there's no reason to think they wouldn't
do that again
yeah that laptop from hell is really
something congressman we've got we've
got to look at that hard drive
especially um last thing i want to ask
about how much in the uh among your
colleagues is there discussion of the
mar-a-lago search warrant and just the
you know 60 truth social posts a day
from the former president like something
is very very wrong over there how much
does that play in the day-to-day between
you and your colleagues and sort of
considering that side of what's taking
place
in as you think about your 2022 campaign
and then moving beyond 22 or is it
wholly irrelevant to what you and your
colleagues are doing
well we've tried not to talk about it
that much because it's a law enforcement
matter and we've actually tried not to
politicize it i mean the last thing you
want is uh every democratic member of
congress going on uh cnn or your podcast
giving an opinion on what the justice
department should do right that said
what does come up uh are the threats
frankly uh that colleagues are facing uh
in this environment and they're more
than i've ever seen in in six years you
had uh eric swalwell post yesterday
about the threat he received one of his
staffers received uh really ugly things
and unfortunately i'm hearing that kind
of uh threats and violence much more
from colleagues
which is concerning
are there
i mean obviously we i don't want you to
share what's being done but is there a
different or more
involved sort of security apparatus that
is that is now involved because of this
there is but
you can't protect in an open democracy
uh
everyone from a culture of violence i
mean look members of congress uh we we
are in parades i was just in the pride
parade in san jose we are we do town
halls with hundreds of people we sit in
coffee shops and that's how it's
supposed to be
and for many many decades
people did that at both parties without
really worrying
about political violence i mean
obviously you had uh crazy shootings and
mass shootings but those were one-off
incidents now you're at a point where
there are
members of congress unfortunately who
will be advised to sit out a town hall
or a parade or community events and this
is a one of the real damages that
doesn't get talked about enough in our
democracy
that the right is causing which is this
uh
fear of being connected to people yeah
and sadly the sort of
growing belief among some
that violence is an acceptable way to
try to achieve political change or to
make your opinions known which is really
scary and that goes to the gun culture
aspect as well right seeing guns as a
legitimate tool to solve interpersonal
problems
you know when i was growing up the the
one thing almost a cliche was while in
america we solve our political problems
without violence we have a peaceful
transfer of power i mean everyone would
say that is sort of pointing to why
we're the greatest democracy and it's
sad to me that something uh that basic
is now being
being questioned fortunately uh we still
uh are in a relatively peaceful place
and these are threats and they haven't
uh become full for full-born uh
assassination attempts but in other
countries you know you literally have uh
political parties trying to
assassinate uh each other and we've got
to be very careful that we don't cross
uh into a line where violence becomes
condoned as part of the political
culture yeah we don't want to we don't
want to end up there and lindsey graham
earlier this week getting dangerously
close to that but we'll we'll leave that
for for another conversation
we've been speaking with democratic
congressman ro connor who represents
california's 17th district always a
pleasure having you on
thank you really appreciate it
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow all right i have some dr
oz gigacringe for you today this is uh i
i have never seen anything like this
this is maybe the most awkward moment
from any political rally i've ever seen
short of when trump a few weeks ago
tried to kiss that swimmer and she kind
of like
just tried to get away from him um
mehmet oz is a television doctor and of
course as we spoke about earlier and as
as we have been speaking about he's
running in pennsylvania for the senate
he's the republican nominee his opponent
is john fetterman i would suggest voting
for john fetterman i think fetterman is
a better candidate and um
there was a guy who wanted to ask oz
about abortion
and dr oz puts
straps a blood pressure cuff to the guy
and i don't think i've ever seen
anything this bizarre take a look at
this tell me a little bit about
so awkward
abortion yes
you know while i take your blood
pressure i will answer that question
sir wow
you know is there a limit to it is there
a you know a time when
women should be allowed to get an
abortion or is it this is an issue that
really affects this man significantly
you can tell should we ban it all
together
so
as you all probably know i'm pro-life
but i have three exceptions and i spoke
about them a lot in the primary i'm a
doctor i appreciate the realities of
taking care of people who are struggling
don't get nervous
so um so i think the life of the mother
rape incest these are
problems that i think families should
have the ability to deal with and it's
hard to expect the government to deal
with yeah
what in god's name is happening in this
country folks if fetterman doesn't win
this one
i might have to end the show and leave
the political world and just kind of go
out into the woods and just live some
kind of primitive life because i mean
and actually if oz or herschel walk or
win
i'm gonna need to go and have a deep
think
about my life
beyond just being bizarre
what doctor takes blood pressure when
someone's legs are crossed and they're
talking and while they're holding their
arm up in the air i mean it just it's
terrible blood pressure technique wasn't
he a cardiac surgeon he should know this
stuff
and politically here's another very
strange moment from the same rally
where oz compares
homeless people
to zombies with needles sticking out of
their necks and you can just tell he
would be an empathetic senator can't you
go down to downtown philadelphia i see a
little bit in pittsburgh now too but
more in philadelphia i seen it there are
whole blocks i mean like multiple blocks
of areas you can't go there are addicts
walking like zombies you know into the
streets with needles sticking out of
their necks really just
vivid imagery there from mehmet oz this
guy is horrible i mean truly truly
horrible and he has no business being in
the united states senate if you look at
people currently running
are there i mean
i would say any random school teacher
would be
better for the country as one of the 100
members of the united states senate than
memit oz or herschel walker these seem
like two of the worst people just not
worst candidates just if you said to me
david who would be bad people to be in
the senate i would say well herschel
walker would be terrible
and mehmet oz would be terrible to be in
this these people shouldn't be anywhere
near the senate and yet
they could end up collectively making up
two percent right one fiftieth of the
senate let's hope that that doesn't
happen
donald trump has cracked he unleashed a
dangerous 60-plus post tirade on his
failing website truth social yesterday
truth essential this is now it's no
longer funny if it was ever funny it is
absolutely no longer funny trump woke up
and went on a 60 post q a on fueled
social media spree
writes rolling stone now i am not
going to publicize the subject matter in
detail of what donald trump is posting
here but i encourage you
just glance at trump's truth central
account and you will see derangement and
i i was scrolling scrolling scrolling
there is no shortage of memes and
conspiracy theories here it's just memes
and this is a former president folks
it's a former president
your enemy is not in russia trump
re-trothing with pictures of democrats
and george soros that's a classic 81
million votes and i've never seen a
pro-biden hat shirt or flag in my life
right this is a thing on the right
if there aren't people sycophantically
wearing biden memorabilia or
paraphernalia
he can't possibly have supporters well
maybe we on the left don't see these
elected officials like pseudo-deities
i've never gotten gear for any elected
official i've supported because i have a
life and i will vote for them and then i
move on with my life and i don't get
hats or whatever the case may be um
just all you know orwell-related memes
um
just all sorts of and and
you could spend an hour scrolling and
half of these memes are cue and
unrelated trump posting one it's like a
photo this this one's actually funny but
it's a little unbecoming of a president
to post
a a photoshop of buying
falling on the stairs of air force one
with a bicycle and a helmet on the floor
uh an ultra maga post america first
fbi sex tape conspiracy theories
um
weird things of
adam schiff with an exploding cigar
um
you know you could you could just look
redacted with nancy pelosi's eyebrows
covered with black bars black sensor
bars
um stuff about the fbi
um a picture of a broken clock it just
ah and and it's just scrolling and
scrolling and scrolling and scrolling
this is a very sick man and i believe is
it it is a terrified man fundamentally
that's what i believe this is and by the
way folks the entire time i've been
talking i've been scrolling through the
memes trump won
with trump sitting at a desk
a meme of trump posting to dollar
gasoline
um
we're still scrolling scrolling
scrolling scrolling any one of these if
we had a democratic president posting
them would be cause for significant
concern and it is like 24 even a 30 hour
potentially upper fueled
uh
[Music]
series of posts and it's endless i'm
still scrolling folks still still
scrolling so listen i think there's a
couple different things going on here i
think trump is very scared i think trump
at this point the rnc has all but
abandoned him they're no longer paying
his legal fees the pictures came out
where after all of the denials denials
denials that donald trump took uh
documents there are pictures of the
documents with his
you know very cliche casino rugs in his
apartment or muralago suite or whatever
the hell is where he lives uh and also
he is increasingly being abandoned by
more republicans again the vast majority
of the republican party is still behind
him but he is increasingly being
abandoned i think he's scared and i
think he is losing it um none of the
excuses or the lies are working he
doesn't have bill barr or the government
at his disposal to try to deflect he
doesn't have bill barr out there writing
letters that say oh
mueller exonerated him even though when
that's not actually what the mueller
report said the guy is unhinged and all
he has left is his failing
truth central and by the way that will
probably be underwater soon as well
so
some could call it sad
to me the sad thing is he'll probably
never really face the consequences he
deserves
we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 david p
here is i'm trying to understand this
voicemail so hopefully you can help me i
believe that this is a
conservative hispanic caller
who says white progressives are the
worst and i think he's talking about me
even though i'm hispanic
i think that as a hispanic
white progressives are the most racist
uh
i think you white progressives need
to stop telling
we
hispanics or people in color in general
of what to think
this is just another form of slavery
that you're trying to attempt here so
let me i'm i am going to say
an example where i agree with this
caller okay but then most of this
voicemail is a dumpster fire
one of the things i don't like
is
something that has been imposed
by mostly white progressives and that is
latin x rather than latino
latina okay
latinx
i am a progressive
and i am also hispanic
and i don't like it i don't know
any actual hispanic people who use that
and so i've said before
latin x did not arise
uh
naturally
from within the community
it was sort of like imposed by uh mostly
white progressives and that one thing i
am against but most of this voicemail is
bonkers you're not only trying to tell
us what to think but how to think i'm
sorry homosexuality is wrong abortion is
wrong so this is a conservative hispanic
individual
so why don't you white progressives just
simply
leave us alone and stop brainwashing our
people thank you bye all right well
listen um there is a large poor i mean
it should be said that along with jewish
folks
overall
uh hispanic americans are quite
progressive that's actu that that's the
truth of the matter and so
don't blame white progressives
for hispanic voters being in favor of
legal abortion and being in favor of gay
marriage uh most of these positions we
came to on our own so kind of a weird
caller pretty unhinged
with like one tiny little fraction of a
grain of truth there we have a great
bonus show for you today
we will talk about the passing
of uh the last soviet leader gorbachev
mikhail gorbachev who passed away at age
91. we are going to talk about
california fast food workers very close
to winning some historic protections and
we will talk about the incredible viral
video of a black pastor
watering his neighbor's flowers
and the police show up and it is crazy
crazy video
all of those stories and more when i am
joined by producer pat on today's bonus
show oh the bonus show where you want to
make money everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad yeah
well you can judge for yourselves when
you sign up at
joinpackman.com you can use the coupon
code big voting22 to get a discount and
i will see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
real quick go check out jayatal the uk's
most exciting electronic music duo their
newest release connected is available
wherever you get music it's energetic
melodic blast of electronica ingeniously
infused with acoustic instruments and
they support the david pakman show check
them out using the link below